hey friends and welcome back to rapid  fire language learning today we're  answering the question how to get a  great accent in a foreign language  getting a great accent or great  pronunciation in a foreign language is  not as difficult as people make it out  to be but you need to have two  important things in place first you have  to identify yourself with the language  at a visceral  level great training is not enough  you have to be able to embrace a new  culture  at a deep level if you want to speak a  language well with great pronunciation  and second  you have to train and start working on  your pronunciation  from the get-go if you have these two  things in place you will get a great  pronunciation  in a foreign language if you want to  know more about pronunciation  accent acquisition and many other things  within the language learning world  please check out my channel  over and out